Oh putain...!
J'en peux plus depuis qu'il se branle plus il est tout le temps sur moi.
J'ai peur.
Karine ?
Ça fait déjà une semaine que l'interdiction de se masturber est entrée en vigueur et pour ne pas
succomber à la tentation les sites internet suivants viennent d'être fermés :
YouPorn, RedTube, Pornhub, Youjizz ...
Youjizz...!
Ouais j'ai mes règles, ouais
Nouvelle interpellation :
le jeune homme a été surpris en train de se masturber dans sa propre maison.
Il sera jugé demain pour crime contre l'humanité.
Mmmm, ça a l'air bon.
Dégage !
Je veux plus te voir !
Lâche-la, les mains sur la tête !
Non ! Je m'en fous je vais le faire !
Pose ta bite, j'te dis !
Non...!
Ta bite, vite !
J'en peux plus, mec.
J'arrête pas de me toucher la bite sans m'en rendre compte.
À ton avis, combien de fois faudrait se branler
pour tuer tous les mecs sur Terre ?
Mais ça ferait de nous des monstres.
Non...
Ça ferait de nous des Dieux.
Oui ben voilà ça y'est,
on m'informe que La Redoute a décidé de fermer la section "Lingerie" de son catalogue...
C'est la merde !
T'façon on a plus qu'à crever comme des cons...!
Ça y'est !
On peut baiser qui on veut maintenant,
on n'aura plus à se branler, mec.
Qu'est-ce que tu fous ?
Non !
Non ! Non ! Non !
Non ! Non ! Non ! Non !
Arrête ! Arrête !